joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line on the rich eisen show
is a man who is keeping the old school
sports center light on every single
night at midnight when he hosts his
version of sportscenter he's also the
host of the sv pod scott van pelt back
here on the rich eisen show how are you
scott
better it's been been too long been too
long and it has been i i i i you know
how this goes in this business right
like you your friends that you watch and
i'll i'll see you whether it's some clip
i see on twitter or wherever and and
hopefully vice versa somehow you're
vaguely aware of what we're doing and
and but this is so much better to
actually you know sort of shake hands
and hug from afar thanks for having me
back is exactly that and you know um
i i was thinking of you the other day
um because i i whenever stuart pops in
my brain i think of the folks at
sportscenter and espn who
were there with him back in the day and
stuart pops in my brain anytime
um
north carolina does well in anything
and i i'm like you know who can i call
to reach out to to have this
conversation about stuart scott and what
we're seeing right now because what
we're seeing right now is not just a run
by north carolina the fact that
here they are again
now in the final four
against coach k
again after what happened at cameron
and this could be coach k's last game or
not and it's their first final four
appearance this is off the charts and
i'm like i gotta call scott and just
throw that in your lap which i just did
love it uh you know
it makes me it makes me smile to think
about uh you know our friend and it it
made me remember
being
on the set
at uh
ten years ago now which is impossible to
fathom but it's 2012
and stuart and i are going to follow
duke carolina
and it's in chapel hill and
carolina is winning fairly comfortably
most of the game and then it's one of
those things that happens in rivalry
games which starts to maybe duke's got a
shot here maybe just got a shot here
well austin rivers hit the shot
they went at the buzzer 85-84 now this
is very inside tv
but i'll explain it in a way that would
hopefully make sense if you don't do tv
when you're following a live event and
the director gets in your ear the ifb
the thing that's in your ear and says
next counts to us what that means is the
the event is is live they've just hit
this miraculous shot but in 20 seconds
you're on
and stuart and i are meant to follow
this game
and
you know it's got a massive audience
because the game's incredible and
carolina has just lost like this and
their next counts to us and they're
counting it down and stuart and i are
just standing there silence and i look
at him
and i say if you leave i'll understand
if that happened to maryland i'm gone
i'm leaving now and he's like no he's
like no no he just gives you like that
like he gave you like his hand yeah i'm
good
and of course the red light comes on and
no one's better and
he managed to just eat that gigantic l
that duke cooked up for him and we did a
show and i just was smiling and laughing
thinking about that because
there's nothing you can do
um when you have ex when the world knows
and you do it with michigan i do it with
maryland he did it with carolina
we're all from somewhere that's where
we're from yes and uh and he was proud
of it and he wore it proudly and he wore
it
valiantly in defeat and that night was
defeat but my god rich the idea of
carolina and duke in the final four i
happened to be in cameron for that final
game where
uh for coach k and carolina played
brilliantly and i think it changed their
season and i also think it changed duke
season because it got their attention
yes it did um it's just remarkable
imagine this i want you to think about
this
ohio state ohio state
hosts no michigan hosts ohio state jim
harbaugh has become the winningest
football coach in the history of college
football ohio state comes to ann arbor
and
harbaugh's last game and they beat him
and then
harbaugh and michigan get a chance to
play ohio state in the college football
playoff
and imagine what you'd feel because
that's what stewart would be feeling
right now yeah because
there really is that's i'm trying to put
it in
any sort of perspective here and the
only thing that can come to it is you
know packers bears in an nfc
championship game you know although that
that that wound up you know in the hands
of caleb haney a couple years ago you
know
i should have i should have front loaded
it because that does sound disrespectful
the way i said it um you know and then
you know yankees red sox alcs
and but you know it wasn't like the end
of tory's career and i don't even know
you know if tory even with when all
those winning all that winning you know
he wasn't there for 40 years like coach
k and isn't the winningest manager in
the history of baseball like like you
can't i don't know if this is any
comparison
we've seen it it's happened right like
it's crazy it is it's happened yes i
mean this is auburn alabama in the in
the playoff it's it's ohio state
michigan in a playoff it's something
that has never happened in the history
of
clearly one of the greatest rivalries in
sports and now it's happening and it's
not just happening rich it's happening
as mike shashefsky the winningest coach
that we've ever had
is leaving and you if you're carolina is
as fantastic as it was for you to go
into cameron and spoil the party imagine
if you get to end his career
like no one from duke ever gets to say
anything to you ever again you close up
shop that's it you just wave your hand
and go no no no no no no no
no no no no no stop talking stop talking
right
yeah
that's the feral riley scene in
that's it that's essentially what is on
the line right and and uh that and that
and again that's why
i think of stuart you know about what he
would be thinking uh about this
and this is
you know we use hyperbole although all
the time in what we do for a living sean
van pelt but
this is the biggest duke carolina game
ever and i don't know how
there could be another because there
won't be another coach k right there
won't be another first time that they
meet i mean hubert davis being involved
in it is is an interesting plot twist
you know
um for sure but this is the biggest
carolina duke game ever and there won't
be another
like it you could make that case easily
no and then and then
the fact that the the other game right
like
villanova and kansas are
i mean and this is this is i don't know
if there's even a debate necessarily but
i mean as as as the blue bloods go
nova is new to it in a sense because you
know they don't have the history that
digs back 60 years or whatever but i
mean when you're top 10 all-time in
final fours and you're top 10 all-time
titles one then in my opinion you're
you're blue blood jay wright i think is
is the next k in the sense of a guy that
never has to leave where he is for
anything and i think we'll will be the
statesman of the game from where he is
um
for as long as he chooses to be there
but what i'm getting at is it's them
against kansas who's also on that list
of team that's won a ton of titles and
has gone to a boatload of final fours
and they're sort of like the other game
right yeah i mean it's they're massive
massive programs um who won titles you
know in recent memory and yet
it's caroline and duke at 9 40 on a
saturday night in new orleans my god
it's like look we are guilty of
hyperbole and lord knows
you worked here i do work here we're
capable of of of making it uh a bit
nauseating at times right at the shop
right we can because we can the tonnage
of conversation about it just gets to be
like enough but in this case
if anything's justifying it in sports
this justifies it
um and the fact that carolina did go to
cameron and win already which really
launched them and changed the whole
trajectory of their season
um it's it's what makes
what we are lucky enough to do talk
about sports so much fun uh and it's you
know it's only tuesday and i have
nothing to do with this game but i'm
just i'm pacing around my kitchen right
now like like throw the ball up and go i
know that's amazing scott van pelt here
on the rich eisen show and you just
mentioned the the tonnage uh of coverage
that is uh potentially weighty for the
fans to consume you know with coach k
in his final final four and it's against
unc and you know the coverage can be uh
significant uh but that would only be a
walk in the park if tiger
appears at matt at the masters at
augusta national the following week do
you think that's
possible scott van pelt
rich i have gone from
waving remember the waving my hand
yes i'm coming off stupid you're wearing
tuxedos to an interview for cleaning
bathrooms sorry i'm doing step brothers
um
i would have i did dismiss that i just
it was not happening there's no chance
this is happening right and now it's the
tuesday before
the masters week and it's
it's not not happening
it's it's there's enough
of a of a waft of the possibility in the
air
and and here's where i here's what
here's what i know is that i don't know
all right i don't know if he can but it
certainly appears rich that they're that
they're going to kick the tires on
how he
how he feels about it
and the thing about augusta national as
has been mentioned so often is it is the
hilliest golf course
that that players uh compete on in major
championships and the man nearly lost a
limb and so you can roll your eyes about
golfers on athletes and then that's fine
but i'll promise you this walking
when you play golf do you walk or do
your ride i don't know a ton of people
that walk because at the end of it
you're like man that's more than you
thought well augusta is a walk that is
that taxes players in a different way
and so
if he can do it
i i it wouldn't shock me if he tried
and
you know um a guy that i work with whose
name you'd know and again this is inside
tv but he's legendary in our business
his name's mike mcquaid and he's the guy
i work for doing doing golf and we were
talking about it last night i said like
so this is when we talk about anything
else prior to thursday morning and he
said well of course but just the idea of
tiger on a range swinging a club that
he's going to play thursday morning
it would be
it'd be a lot to for us to discuss and
it would be great for every other player
because then they could just very
casually
stroll down
down the middle of the fairway doing
their work and nobody be talking about
him or paying attention to him because
just the idea that woods was back giving
it a go would be
uh storyline a but you think wherever he
is right now he's sitting there thinking
about it you think that he's
he's going through whatever
um physical places he needs to yes i do
i i i i've known him a long time and i
know that he is he if there's a if
there's a
it's the old arnold palmer right where
if you're in the woods but you kind of
see that window between the trees you're
like right through there baby
well let's find out
i mean
and i don't know using that analogy i
don't know if he's got a small window or
if he feels like he's got i got an
opening here let's let's see i mean only
he knows physically how he feels but if
he he i think he did an incredible job
of just
poking
that balloon anytime he was asked right
when he was when when they were out in
your neck of the woods at riviera and he
was on cbs with jim nance and he was
talking about look i
i mean it was just dismissive entirely
dismissive like i just i haven't had a
chance to practice i mean i can't you
can't go there and do this unless you
can do a b c and d and i just haven't
been able to do that
well if he's been able to do that
between then and now
and he has
you know any shot of of giving it a go
here's the thing rich he's he's won it
and he's allowed back as long as he's as
he's ambulatory and wants to compete so
it's not like he goes out and shoots a
big number and doesn't get to come back
i mean
nothing ventured nothing gained right if
he can do it so
i don't know maybe i'm talking myself
into something crazy here um and maybe
maybe he doesn't but it just
the fact that we're even having the
conversation i wouldn't have i wouldn't
have thought was possible uh a week ago
and now it's like there's there's enough
chatter about it that i you know i
wonder just to bring it all full circle
then wisconsin's you know you and i are
professional bringing all full circle
people yeah uh
well you know what um i am
i agree um so putting it all together if
unc beats duke and then cuts down the
nets and then tiger reappears at augusta
after everything then we know stuart
scott is pulling some levers wherever
he's sitting right now above us yeah
then we know that that would be the fact
that i'll top my chest and point my
finger to the sky and say my man
we're thinking of you as we often do and
we appreciate you that would certainly
indicate that
that he's got some he's got some sweat
he's got some sway he's got some juice
we all know he does as we turn our
pillow over to the cool side so i'll
tell you this story uh in letting you go
i don't know if i've ever told you the
story but um stuart scott and i were at
a jimmy v golf tournament the famed
jimmy v
uh the v foundation um
uh charity and there was the golf
tournament down in raleigh
and it was huge man back in the day late
90s
michael jordan would be there and and
and uh charles barkley and all the all
the college coaches would be there in
raleigh in the middle of the summer
so stewart and i pull up we're getting
ready to play golf and we're at the bag
drop at the at the golf course
and who pulls up but
mike shishevsky okay in the car and he
drops off his bag
at the bag drop and we watch him
maneuver his car to go back to the
parking lot and it was a k-turn we
watched him make a k-turn in his car and
stuart and i looked at each other and
were like did we just watch coach k
make a k-turn in his car
and it's similar to that sportscenter
commercial like you and him watching
arnold palmer making an arnold palmer it
literally was a real life this is
sportscenter commercial with stuart and
i'm watching that how is nobody how is
it how is no one rolling tape because
it's before twitter before everything
you know the most iconic of those spots
are just those is arnold palmer making
iced tea and lemonade and stew there's
nothing to say
you watch the man make a cater now did
stewart go casually walk over and key
the man's car
no i do believe one of the people he
dropped off was roy williams who stewart
would always tell because he was with
kansas at the time that he was at the
wrong school
you know he would tell roya frequently
that uh he needed to come home which he
eventually did as we all know but no he
did not stew
you know stu definitely loved coach k
and everything about it but when it all
came down to it i i think it was a duke
carolina game that stuart and i when we
were first paired together we were on
right after unlike an 11 o'clock sports
center and dick vitale
mentioned us hey stick around for rich
and stew what a great team they are
and we looked at each other like okay
where we have arrived and you know right
off just to bring it all you know
together mike mcquaid who you just
mentioned was the
the producer the in the year of dan and
keith for the big show and um so we were
trying to
you know um be just as big as them or as
significant as that team and when we
heard dick say that we kind of looked at
each other like okay this is pretty cool
you know that's you know what that's
that's such a great story because you
know dick dick has that kind of thing
you know i mean where he he was
i mean not a king maker in the sense but
but if he took if he took note
of who you were at at a time before you
became what you became right that's a
little bit of just you know just get
your chest a little swollen feel good
about it and then you you know off you
go and you do a show and
what what what fun it is to remember
right um
you did it i was lucky enough to do it
sit there with stuart following a
carolina duke game and you know and now
now here comes the biggest one there's
ever been that's uh i you did you did me
a favor by uh by reaching out because it
i got a gigantic smile on my face
thinking about my friend and uh and uh
you know i appreciate that it's great
fun to remember you the man scott van
pelt love you brother let's do this more
often and anytime i could be of any uh
you know guest service to you i'm always
around you know that my man i appreciate
you uh be well rich until next time stay
good okay you the man at not the fake
svp i must follow on twitter i do it you
should as well scott van pelt here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here